hey I was going bros my name is peter
pan this week I'm in Italy right at the
beach right now it's really nice just
taking a couple days off you might say
what are you doing I'm just gonna kind
of low-key vlog the trip just like what
we're doing and stuff like that doing
this way let's go it's really nice
gonna try not to drop my phone cuz it's
my only vlogging camera
Jesus Christ what is this hair why am i
a mushroom on ously not flexing at all
okay so hey how's it going
ah being vlogger is the worst too much
man
it was a joke I am doing nothing and yo
YouTube welcome to my crib this is my
castle my million-dollar castle I live
in this tower this is where Marcia lives
I'm honestly just trying to make this
video ten minutes by at this point of
course I can't make it one one day in
the Sun without becoming a lobster you
can't really see Swedish jeans they're
just the best not the jeans the jeans
the jeans whatever okay I'm gonna go for
a run now all right bye bag huh okay
feel stupid
this is ridiculous
oh man is that smudgy I reached the end
I guess I'll go back I think that was
like eight kilometers or something
correction that was probably more like
200 kilometers just just to be clear
holy [ __ ] I'm not used to running in
that heat man that was [ __ ] brutal
I'm gonna take a cold shower you can
imagine me naked if you want that's okay
so I took a shower put on a new shirt
sat down for five minutes this happened
what does that baby doing there are the
looks are nice and sprout alerts weird
joke okay I guess I need a new shower we
just had dinner it's super late it's oh
my god 9:30 that's super late I need to
go to sleep that sorry I said okay bye
now
goodnight first day in Italy I'll see
you tomorrow
okay so day two we're just checking out
some places in Italy I don't really know
where we are but it's very pretty
would you look at that
I forgot how hot this country is I'm
literally melting this is no place for a
Swede I don't like those are coming from
the nipples the boob fountain fontana
del ataque at least I have my thumbnail
stored it now it's perfect
ladies nerd oh she can hear us at board
Oh architecture look at that Wow
that's so cool hey are they coming here
oh my god
superfast come on come on but I'll save
you
this is definitely my face and when I
see ducks maybe you know this but we
used to live in Italy for a while and
this is where we would sleep that's like
oh it's the Marseilles one I drank this
ones when I was like really terrible
this is my corner my headlamp wish I
would always keep when I need a day
mm-hmm are you mom saved all this stuff
yeah my very cool wristband which I of
course this and I was like why the hell
would I have saved this this is a famous
Swedish guy but it says from with love
my dear
am i very cool brofist I would wear this
all the time I found my old notebook
kill my see guess I failed on that one
clay I'm yuusha custom story Fridays
with PewDiePie ah those were the days I
want to go down to my office my office
does anyone recognize where we are oh my
god
Jesus Christ there this is for Peter pie
started this is where Peter pie of the
Internet in a place that barely has in
her name oh my god there used to be so
many bugs down here like really big ones
oh my god so yeah like I had it pretty
nice I would keep my playstation here on
top of the stove oh man dude this takes
me back
sorry I my battery died yesterday so I
didn't vlog anything else but we're
going to gather the line now which is
like Disneyland for Italian people
except everything is copyrighted I don't
know how they get away with it it's
really cold out I'm really excited
I've been here once before I'll take you
around some rides I'll take you for a
ride baby just you can come with me it's
gonna be fine
just to hold my hand and feel safe this
theme park doesn't play around hardcore
oh my god they want you to have a see
you sure before you enter I swear that's
Tony the Tiger
and that's someone on drugs this is like
the dankest kids play I really want to
go on this one I never been on this one
I don't know what oh my god
is way too close man way too close dude
I'm on 1% battery but today was really
fun and I'll see you tomorrow good bye
okay final day in Italy we're going to
this place that might say describes his
mind blowing this is her city and she
told me to vlog it so I'll check it out
I guess I don't really know that's
really cool
this is very cool I don't know what it
is though I got a ceiling and everything
amazing just thought I found some more
buildings in case you haven't seen
enough buildings there's a couple more
here we got an epic view very nice
okay I didn't vlog the last day I'm
sorry we're going home now it's raining
so it spits I had a really good trip it
was really fun I felt like I need a
little break even though I still I still
vlog a little bit but I'm glad you bros
got come along got spent more time with
Martin CI which is really nice as well
and then yeah I hope you boys enjoyed
this vlog please leave a like if you did
and let me know if you want more of
these and I will be sure to vlog if I
ever go somewhere and as always